Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a comedy family film
called “I'm Underage But I'm Not a
Child”. Watch out and take care!
Oriyama Karin is the daughter of a billionaire
businessman, Oriyama Kazuki. She has been treated
like a princess from a young age and knows little
to nothing about the world outside her mansion.
Karin has everything she wants and her only dream
is to marry a prince one day. On the morning of
her sixteenth birthday, her personal bodyguard
Kaburaki and the maids wake her up and carry
her to the bathroom. Karin, who is still half
asleep, doesn't realize she is being picked up.
They bathe her and get her ready in her school
uniform. After being pampered, she is told that
she has received gifts from several billionaires
from around the world like Mark Zukerberg and
Bernard Arnault. She is then seated in her limo
and driven to school like usual. On her way,
her classmate and friend Ebina Isuzu brings her
flowers. Like Karin, he also belongs to a wealthy
family. He has had a crush on her for a long time
but she only thinks of him as a friend. At school,
Karin hears the girls gush about a good looking
guy who has just been admitted to the school. She
follows them to take a look at him herself. Like
the other girls, Karin is also mesmerized by Nao
Tsurugi’s beauty. Watching him play football,
she instantly feels attracted to him. Without
thinking much about it, she walks to the field
and is hit by the ball. The impact almost makes
her fall when Nao catches her. Because of the
gesture, the princess falls in love with him.
In the evening, her parents throw an extravagant
birthday party for her. They sing, dance,
and have a lot of fun. For her gift, Karin
is given a wedding dress. It turns out that
a prophet had told her father that she is bound to
get married the day after her sixteenth birthday.
The husband will turn Karin into a better person
and will provide her life long happiness. Karin
refuses to marry anyone who is not Nao. She throws
a fit, breaking the utensils and destroying the
place without letting her father explain himself.
Only after he shows her the picture of her future
husband does she realize that she is being married
to Nao. Kazuki has bought her a husband of her
choice for her sixteenth birthday. The following
day, she and Nao are at the altar. When they are
asked to exchange rings, he claims that since they
are keeping their marriage a secret, it is better
if they skip that part. Karin is ready to do as
he says so she doesn’t object. Since they are too
young to be married, they have decided to not tell
anyone at school. After the wedding, he brings
her to his house that only has one bedroom that is
the size of her closet at her mansion. She is told
that she will have to adjust now that her husband
is poor. Karin is skeptical about how two people
are going to fit in the house but she trusts
her husband to make her feel comfortable.
She is excited about her first night with Nao but
is confused when he asks her to stay in her side
of the room. He reveals that he doesn’t love her
and only married her because he wanted to inherit
her father’s wealth. He calls her shallow for
choosing him because of his looks and also says
that he hates her. Karin falls asleep hoping
that everything that happened is just a dream.
When she wakes up the next day it is already 10
pm. She doesn’t have a habit of waking up on her
own so she is late for school. The landlady
tells her that Nao left early in the morning
without her. Karin tries to take a shower but
doesn’t know how to turn on hot water. Getting
ready for school is difficult for her without the
help of her maids. After struggling to do basic
tasks the entire morning, she leaves for school
but gets lost in the way. After wandering around
the city for hours, she reaches school when it is
already over. Isuzu asks her where she had been
all day but Karin cannot tell him because then
she would have to explain that she got married.
When she reaches home at night, a furious Nao is
waiting for her to explain the mess she had made
in the house. She cries about not knowing how to
do simple tasks which makes him feel bad for her.
Starting the next day, he promises to help
her get used to the new lifestyle.
He teaches her to turn on hot water, to clean
using a vacuum cleaner, and to cook instant
ramen. In only a few days, Karin gets used to
her new life. One day, she cooks a meal for him
which surprisingly tastes delicious. However,
Nao soon finds out that she used almost half
of their monthly allowance for the meal. As he
starts to panic, Karin simply calls her father
Kazuki to ask for money. The pair is called to
the mansion where they explain the situation to
her father. He offers to help them but Nao
declines it. He wants to live on a budget
and not take advantage of Kazuki’s kindness. The
parents are impressed by his wise words. At night,
the couple stays at the mansion. The next morning
when they are about to leave, Karin apologizes
to the cooks for always throwing their food away.
After she started to cook for herself she realized
how difficult of a task it is. Her parents and
bodyguard Kaburaki are shocked. They erupt into
cheers claiming that this is the first time she
has apologized to anyone. During school lunch,
the pair sit at different tables to not seem
suspicious. Karin’s friend Isuzu notices her
looking at Nao but doesn’t think much of it. When
a group of girls surround Nao offering him food,
she gets jealous and asks them to go away.
When she realizes what she did, she makes up an
excuse and sits down quietly. A girl named
Saaya looks at Nao and walks away angrily.
Nao calls her by her name which makes Karin even
more jealous. On reaching home, she confronts him
about Saaya but Nao refuses to talk. When she
insists, he storms out of the house. They see
each other again in the morning but do not talk.
Karin makes it her mission to find out about Saaya
and Nao’s relationship. She hardly has to do
anything because Saaya approaches her during
lunch break and asks her if she is dating Nao.
Karin wants to tell her she is married to him
but she refrains from it. Saaya assumes that
they are dating and asks her to break up with
him immediately. She claims that he is only
dating her for money and will leave her once
his school debt is paid. An innocent Karin sees
no wrong in dating someone for money. In fact,
she is happy to give him some since her father has
a lot of it. Nao listens to their conversation,
delighted that Karin didn’t overreact. At home,
he helps her dry her hair and is nicer in general.
Karin notices the change in behavior but doesn’t
say anything. The next day, Nao finds out that
Karin has been passing her tests with the help
of her bodyguard and her friend Isuzu. Hence,
he starts to tutor her every day.
At first, Karin struggles to keep up but
she soon gets a hang of it. She even takes notes
in class surprising her teacher and classmates.
Nao agrees to go on a date with her if she gets
good grades which encourages her to study harder.
One day she is in the library when Isuzu asks her
if she is dating someone. Karin tells him she just
wants to get better grades but he has started
to suspect her. She gets an A on her next test
and is overjoyed. While returning home, a crowd of
men in black clothes kidnaps her. They take her to
Isuzu’s mansion. It turns out that he has found
out about her marriage to Nao and doesn’t approve
of it. He threatens to tell the school principal
about it and get them expelled if she doesn’t
divorce him instantly. Karin is left shocked. The
guy she thought was her best friend turned out
to be an obsessive lunatic. Later, she is in one
of the rooms of his house when Nao calls her. He
has been looking for her all day and is worried.
She tells him everything about what happened with
Isuzu and asks him to come to pick her up. Nao
doesn’t think twice before coming to get his wife.
He is welcomed by Isuzu’s bodyguards who do not
let him see Karin before talking to him.
Isuzu knows that Nao married Karin for her money.
He tells Nao that he can never provide Karin with
the love and happiness she deserves. Having known
Karin since childhood, Isuzu knows everything
about her dreams and aspirations. She wanted to
dance with her significant other as a princess
and wanted to have a grand wedding with hundreds
of guests but Nao couldn’t even give her that.
Nao, who has started to fall in love with her,
realizes that she deserves someone like Isuzu
who can fulfill all her wishes. Isuzu asks him
to divorce Karin if he really cares about her.
When Nao later meets her, she asks him to come
home. However, Nao wants her to stay the night
at her parents’ house because his house has no
electricity. She retaliates but he agrees to go on
a date with her tomorrow and calms her. The next
day, they meet on a bridge and go to an aquarium
where Karin had always wanted to visit. Nao
compliments her outfit, making her blush. They eat
several street foods, talk about different things
and run around on the beach. In the end, they sit
down to talk. Karin lists all the things that she
has noticed about Nao, like the fact that he hates
the noise of utensils breaking. He reveals that
his mother used to break stuff when she got mad,
so he has developed a hatred for such noises.
They promise to support each other for eternity
and ring a bell on a shrine. Right after,
Nao suggests they get a divorce.
Karin returns home shocked and devastated. The
next day, Nao drops out of school and gets into
a massive argument with his mother. He wants to
do his best to not see Karin. Karin’s parents are
worried for her but can do nothing to change Nao’s
mind. In the meantime, Isuzu visits her and asks
her to go out with him. He brings her to a palace
where they dance as she had always wanted to with
her prince. Karin enjoys his company but knows
that she would rather live in a tiny home with
Nao than in a palace. When they are done dancing,
Isuzu proposes to her. Somewhere else, Kaburaki
meets Nao and gives him the divorce papers. He
also hands him a princess book that used to be
Karin’s favorite. After reading the book, Nao
gets to know more about what she wants in life.
It also makes him realize that he cannot give her
up at any cost. He runs to Isuzu’s house asking
him to stay out of his and Karin’s relationship.
He appears to be determined about winning her
back. Isuzu tells him that Karin refused to marry
him because she is in love with Nao. He wants her
to be happy even if it means helping her get back
together with him. Nao happily runs back to their
house, knowing that Karin would be there.
The two finally meet each other and kiss.
Karin asks him if he likes her to which Nao
replies that he has fallen in love with her.
Cut to five years later, Karin and Nao
are getting married yet again. This time,
the church is filled with guests, and the
two exchange rings. In the last scene,
they kiss as the crowd erupts in cheers.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.